esto es casi un hábito parang en el
juzgado de Hong Kong este ex demócrata
acude a una visita
muchos de los acusados hoy son amigos
míos Así que he venido a apoyarlos
sus amigos se enfrentan hasta 10 años de
cárcel por organizar unas primarias
demócratas en 2020 este periódico fijará
finalmente una fecha para su juicio
llevan casi dos años esperando entre
rejas a que se celebre su juicio no son
ni mucho menos un caso aislado
hoy en día nos sentimos aturdidos porque
día tras día se condena a personas
apenas de entre 2 y 5 años de prisión
ahora no reconozco
desde la aplicación de la ley de
seguridad nacional en 2020 y las
consiguientes detenciones masivas la
mayoría de opositores de Beijing están
en prisión o en el exilio el poder
judicial de Hong Kong está desbordado de
Procedimientos personalidades políticas
abogados periodistas activistas los
juicios se suceden al igual que los
encarcelamientos solo por las protestas
de 2019 1300 personas están encarceladas
fatzai pasó casi tres años entre estos
muros
cada vez que vuelvo aquí se me vienen a
la mente muchas emociones y malos
recuerdos
aunque fue duro fue el momento fuerte y
significativo en mi vida
al salir sus antecedentes penales le
impiden encontrar trabajo entonces abrió
esta tienda de comestibles
Esta es la nueva dirección de nuestra
tienda
conoció a su socio en la cárcel
también él fue
encarcetaciones prodemocráticas hoy en
día no se trata de proclamar sus
opiniones sino de rendir un homenaje
discreto a los presos
ese dibujo representa a presos políticos
Los ausentes en las comidas familiares
del año viejo
esos cuatro caracteres significan no lo
olvides
la más mínima referencia política como
esta los expone a más persecuciones un
riesgo que asumen
si ya ni siquiera me atrevo a hacer algo
tan pequeño sigue valiendo la pena ser
humano
cualquier crítica a las autoridades
puede considerarse ahora subversiva y
por tanto ilegal y censurable lo que
ahoga poco a poco la disidencia Pero
algunas organizaciones siguen intentando
hacer oír su voz
ha asumido el liderazgo de la liga
social demócrata la mayoría de los demás
miembros están en prisión desde mi punto
de vista el gobierno de Hong Kong
haciendo todo lo posible por controlar y
destruir la sociedad civil se enfrenta a
una creciente intimidación por parte de
las autoridades
si montamos un puesto en la calle la
policía nos vigilará todo el día y nos
firmará estos vídeos pueden utilizarse
como pruebas contra nosotros
para estos activistas se trata de
bordear el límite de lo aceptable de
lidiar constantemente con nuevas normas
nos reunimos con bull sung exdiputado
electo demócrata en el estudio de su
emisora de radio comunitaria creada en
2006 nuestro invitado de hoy se une a
nosotros para la segunda parte del
programa
los telediarios ahora prohibidos en la
banda FM pero que siguen emitiéndose por
internet
el gobierno debe abordar el problema de
covid en su totalidad sigue habiendo
cierta libertad de tono pero con mucha
más cautela
en el pasado la gente siempre criticaba
los errores del gobierno desde la
aplicación de la ley de seguridad
nacional en 2020 y las consiguientes
detenciones masivas la mayoría de los
opositores de Beijing están en prisión o
en el exilio Nadie puede saber realmente
cuándo será inculpado uno a uno los
medios de comunicación independientes
tuvieron que cerrar más de mil
periodistas se quedaron sin trabajo
cinco antiguos empleados del sitio web
de noticias están de news han creado
esta librería dedicada al periodismo
aquí guardan archivos de periódicos
prodemocráticos que no pueden
encontrarse en ningún otro lugar antes
de dejar Hong Kong definitivamente un
lector nos regaló el último del Apple
Daily nuestros ustedes saben que los
mantenemos
diario conocido por su postura contraria
a Beijing cerró en junio del 2021 bajo
la presión de las autoridades un símbolo
del movimiento prodemocrático reducido a
pieza de museo el librero está
preocupado por el futuro de la prensa en
Hong Kong soy muy pesimista enseño
periodismo en la universidad y el número
de jóvenes que siguen queriendo estudiar
ha descendido drásticamente
en la clasificación de la libertad de
prensa de reporteros Sin fronteras Hong
Kong ha pasado del puesto 18 al 148 en
20 años una caída asintomática de la
toma del territorio por Beijing